avez-vous déjà eu peur de naître
avez-vous déjà eu peur de venir au monde
et là normalement en entendant cette
question vous avez un petit froncement
de sourcils quel sens y a-t-il à
demander si on a déjà eu peur de naître
on n'a jamais eu peur de naître parce
qu'avant de naître on ne pouvait pas
avoir peur
vous n'avez jamais eu peur de naître
parce que vous ne pouvez avoir peur qu'à
partir du moment où vous êtes déjà ce
que nous dit Épicure c'est que c'est
exactement la même chose avec la mort on
se pose la question de la mort on
s'inquiète de la mort parce qu'on est
vivant il faut être vivant pour être
inquiet mais ce faisant on est inquiet
de quelque chose qui n'existe pas et
s'inquiéter de quelque chose qui
n'existe pas ça n'a pas de sens la mort
n'est rien si ce n'est un problème de
vivant